regardez la snri savoir moi
[Musique]
moi enfin de la rondo on est rentré en
salon on est tous claqué c'est le froid
la menace change pour m'excuser mais les
petits à nice que tels que la soirée va
finir ratio c'est bon je passe quoi
qu'il arrive c'est à dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma fille je vois en costume officiel -
dresseur n'aurait même pas un bressan le
rendre heureux
[Musique]
une somme qui comprend pas un tube en
dessous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
q
oh
je pense
mais teddy
oui
[Musique]
beaucoup
non deuxième surprise arrive à un
charmant jeune homme il était
passionnant ça a été super bon moment
moi j'étais pas pechoux en laponie nord
du pays des rebelles s'est pas reposé
tout le temps finit par par emballé du
lourd
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
grosse ambiance de noël autour de la
cheminée
mariah carey évidemment qui d'autre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
b